[Music]
it's almost the worst thing you do any
experience and have too much
expectations you can have thoughts of
how it might be going to go but then if
it doesn't what are you going to do you
know like tiger would you have this
thing where he closed his eyes I've seen
some sports therapist open close your
eyes and imagine a perfect shot like
your perfect backswing hitting it
perfectly landing on the on the green
four feet from the cup and he would do
that imagine it and then go and do it
that's the expectation but sometimes
he'd shank one into the high grass and
you can't just go well I thought I'd be
on the green he'd be like it's a new
moment I'm in the high grass and I got
to figure out a way to talk and get out
of that over the sand with water behind
it and hit this new shot you know even
had expectations but don't stick to him
staged fights a real thing it's it's
it's debilitating some people Liz Phair
I think she never toured cuz she had
stage fright which was too bad she was
great she's a musician I think it's a
bad example but I used to be really
frightened my first time I staged I had
to do like two shots does a little beer
and then sip another beer just to get my
hands down like that from that it's a
real thing I know some people have taken
beta blockers I taking pills to like get
rid of there that's that fear I think
with experience you just get over it I
had a time at DC improv where I was
coming out from backstage and I threw up
in my mouth and I had to fucking swallow
back down who's like this next guy he's
originally from supposing you know as
they're saying that he's like please
welcome
had to go out there like that and I was
expecting it but that was real I was
just I don't know what happened I just
got nervous and then there was a time
where I went home to do something like
job job so I was maybe a year two years
in a comedy went home his job came back
and was over to us and while I was
overcome by fright I couldn't get back
on stage
I couldn't do it I would drive from my
apartment
in West LA 30 minutes towards a comedy
store find parking get on my car
walk to the Tom Murray store did you get
an employee spot every week and I was an
employee so you get your three minutes
and it was the highlight of your week
and I would I would park go in
turnaround get back into my car and go
home without getting on stage I couldn't
do it I couldn't do it I didn't know
what to do
I I didn't know what to do it's like a
real thing I'm lost when he when he said
how he dealt with like fear when he's
getting so five seconds to let the fear
in and then not the last two years a lot
for the first five good years so what I
did was I in tension I mean it was that
was going to be in for me if I can't go
onstage I can't be a comic you know so
what I did was I told myself like do
something where it's going to go bad
well you know that ahead of time
so it's like what's the worst that can
happen you know that kind of thing you
tell somebody ask that girl out what's
the worst that can happen to say no and
you're like yeah but it's like bigger
fear and then once you've asked a girl
out enough times excuse me a woman out
enough times and you've gotten rejected
a bunch of times you're like oh that's
not that big a deal what you're gonna
say I have a boyfriend or oh I don't
really want to it's like okay it's like
a little piece of like that didn't feel
good and then it's fine what you
experience gives you that so I went to
the economy store I said I'm not going
to say a word my head I'm like I'm not
going to say anything to my whole time
on stage and I'll just going to see what
happens so I went in I put my tape
recorder down I like press record and
then I was like and then I just kept
looking around and just three minutes of
silence like this can't go well oh hey
it's not gonna it's not gonna affect me
if it doesn't cuz I'm trying to tank it
but then I could get onstage I could
feel what it's like in front of the
crowd actually got a couple laughs too
soft like you know shrugs and stuff and
how ridiculous it was and it was the
tucking of the mic so it was like lime
the bar wasn't up too high but like and
then after that I was able to get back
onstage again I was like that's the
worst I can handle the worst
so now let me go turns out the worst is
not is worse than that the worst is when
you bomb and when you bomb in front of
something you're trying to impress
that's the worst
but that didn't come in till way later
so so I was able to I had to hide by
that but uh yeah that's one method I did
I went into it with like let's let's
suck just to do it you gotta get over it
I don't know it sucks but you got to get
over it yeah I I wouldn't necessarily
suggest people do that but it worked for
me you know I heard the story of a got
some jaws and Close Encounters of the
Third Kind Richard Dreyfuss yeah I hated
going to auditions in Hollywood and they
sit down and be like I calling anyone oh
I actually don't want to do this and
like what do you mean you want to the
audition goes I don't wanna do the part
I just appreciate you calling me in but
this is not a part from the so thank you
but um alright thanks anyway
and he would leave but like what the
fuck and uh and Spielberg I guess caught
wind of it it was like ooh this guy
turned down fuckin parts all over
Hollywood what the fuck it's a high
level parts and I don't know how much of
this is just like truth or just story
but like eventually was like gave him
the part that he wanted now you can't do
that now because if you did that you
your casting director will call your
agent like why you why are you sending
people to waste my time don't send a guy
and your agent call you and say hey what
the fuck man just say you don't wanna do
the audition don't fucking go and waste
people's time and it would never work it
worked for Richard Dreyfuss in that area
at that time
it wouldn't work for anybody else it
would get you in trouble now but find
your own thing so I don't know maybe
that silent thing maybe that would work
for you but but I don't know maybe not
but find your own thing figure out a way
to get back on stage because once you do
it a few times you'll get over it and
let's like a clinical thing I don't know
about clinical like stage fright that
might be worse than like then I'm
talking about but if it's like normal
stage fright get over it
you
[Music]